?
>>> HAPPY '22.
YOU JUST TAPPED INTO THE LIVE
GROUP CHAT ON THE BLEACHER
REPORT.
I'M ALOCK SNGSIDE LIV.
IT IS A NEW YEAR.
I KNOW A LOT OF US HAVE BETTING
RESOLUTIONS.
SO GET IN THE COMMENTS,
EVERYBODY.
TELL ME YOUR NEW YEAR'S BETTING
RESOLUTION.
LIV, DO YOU HAVE ANY?
>> I DO.
NEW YEAR, NEW LIV.
MY PRIORITY THIS YEAR IS STAYING
HEALTHY AND CASHING OUT.
SO AS LONG AS I'M HEALTHY AND
I'M CATCHSHING OUT OF MY BETS, L
BE HAPPY IN 2022.
>> I'M NOT MAD AT YOU FOR THAT.
MUCH I'M NOT MAD AT YOU FOR
THAT.
ALSO SOME BIG NEWS.
OUR NEW YORK BETTERS, SHOUTOUT
TO NEW YORK, I HEARD BETTING HAS
BEEN LEGALIZED IN NEW YORK.
AND FAN DUEL WILL BE LIVE IN NEW
YORK THIS SATURDAY, JANUARY 8th.
SO GET ON FAN DUEL.
REGISTER TO PLACE YOUR BETS
STARTING THIS WEEKEND AS ALWAYS,
AS ALWAYS, WE ARE GIVING AWAY
HOODIES.
WE'RE GIVING AWAY LOCKS AND
JERSEYS.
GET IN THE COMMENTS.
I NEED GIFTS AND EMOJIS AND I
NEED ONERS ONLY.
PLEASE, MATTER OF FACT, I WANT
TO GIVE OUT A JERSEY RIGHT NOW.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I WANT TO GIVE OUT A JERSEY
RIGHT NOW TO A LUCKY COMMENTER
AND I SEE -- I SEE -- HERE WE
GO.
I SEE TOM BRADY HATER.
GREAT USER NAME.
MY GUY'S NAME IS NATHAN.
JAYLON IS GOING TO GO FOR 23.
TATUM IS GOING TORE 32.
I LUKE THAT.
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU WHY.
BUT SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIE.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT, LIV.
IT'S TNT BASKETBALL THURSDAY.
FAN DUEL IS BOOSTING THE THREE
RIGHT IN BOTH GAMES TONIGHT.
THE QUESTION IS, WILL THERE BE
TWO THREE POINTERS IN THE FIRST
THREE MINUTES OF THE GAME?
TODAY WE ASK YOU ON TWITTER.
WHICH THREE BY TWO WILL CASH
TONIGHT?
IS IT THE BOSTON CELTICS TAKING
ON THE NEW YORK KNICKS OR IS IT
THE LOS ANGELES CLIPPERS TAKING
ON THE PHOENIX SUNS?
HERE ARE THE RESULTS.
THERE THEY ARE.
YOU SEE THE CLIPPERS.
THE CLIPPERS AND THE SUNS ARE IN
THE LEAD HERE.
I NEED YOU GUS TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL US WHICH IS A
LOCK.
LIV, TALK TO US.
WHICH ONE DO YOU LIKE BEST?
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, MY PROBLEM IS, IT IS A
TIGHT RACE FOR A REASON.
I WAS ON BOTH SIDES.
THEY RANK TOP FIVE FOR OPPONENTS
HAVING THE LOWEST THREE POINT
PERCENTAGE.
SO BOTH THE CLIPPERS AND SUNS
GUARD THE THREE VERY WELL.
THAT MADE ME WANT TO AVOID THAT
ONE.
THE KNICKS RANKED TOP TEN IN
THREE POINTS ATTEMPTED AND MADE.
THE CELTICS RANK TOP 12 FOR
THREE POINTERS ATTEMPTED AND TOP
15 FOR THREE POINTERS MADE.
SO I ACTUALLY THINK THE SAFER
BET HERE IS THIS CELTICS-KNICKS
MATCHUP.
THAT'S WHAT I'M GOING TO RIDE
WITH.
BUT IT'S A TIGHT RACE.
SO I CAN SEE MAYBE A LITTLE
SPRINKLE ON BOTH LIKE YOU ALWAYS
LIKE TO DO.
>> YOU KNOW I LIKE A SPRINKLE ON
BOTH.
I LIKE TO SPRINKLE IT AROUND.
THAT IS INTERESTING.
THAT ONE IS INTERESTING.
THAT ONE -- THAT UNDER IS KIND
OF LOW.
OVER/UNDER SITTING AT 209,
AROUND THERE.
SO IT'S INTERESTING.
BUT LET ME GET INTO THE
COMMENTS.
I GOT TO SEE WHAT THE PEOPLE ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
AND I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES.
LI
LIV, I SEE BRITTANY.
SHE'S IN AGREEMENT WITH YOU.
Cs AND KNICKS ALWAYS GO WITH THE
UNDERDOG.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, BRITTANY.
YOU'RE WALK AGO WAY WITH A
HOODIE.
SNOOPY IS THE COMMENTS.
KEMBA ALWAYS GOES OFF AGAINST
BOSTON.
HE IS GIVING US PINTER ON WHAT
WE SHOULD BE TAKING IN A SEGMENT
COMING UP SOON.
BUT I GUESS HE IS SAYING TAKE
THE KNICKS MONEY LINE OR KNICKS
SPREAD.
SO SHOUTOUT TO YOU, SNOOPY.
YEAR GETTING A HOODIE.
THAT'S ENOUGH.
I THINK I'M JUST GOING TO MAKE A
DECISION HERE, LIV.
I'M GOING TO MAKE A DECISION
HERE.
THE THREE BY TWO, WE'RE GOING TO
ROCK WITH THE BOSTON CELTICS
TAKING ON THE NEW YORK KNICKS.
I'M MAKING THE DECISION.
I'M PUTTING MY FOOT DOWN AND
BELIEVING IN YOU, LIV.
LET'S ALL RIDE.
LET'S ALL RIDE TOGETHER.
THEY HAVE BEEN AVERAGING, LIV,
49.9 POINTS COMBINED PER GAME.
TODAY WE ASKED YOU IN THE APP,
WHAT WILL THE COMBINED POINT
DOTALS BE TONIGHT?
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL US
WHAT YOU THINK.
AT THE END OF THE GAME, WE'LL DM
ONE RANDOM PERSON WHO GUESSED
CORRECTLY AND HOOK YOU UP WITH A
JERSEY.
LET'S LOOK AT THE CURRENT PLAYER
POINT ODDS HERE.
LIV, WHAT DO YOU LIKE HERE?
>> I THINK THEY HAVE POTENTIAL
TO COVER OVERS.
I'M LOOKING AT JULIUS RANDLE
OVER 21 1/2 POINTS TONIGHT.
I LOVE THE ODDS.
I ALSO LOVE THIS LINE FOR HIM
TONIGHT.
THE CELTICS GIVE UP THE SIXTH
MOST POINTS TO OPPOSING POWER
FORWARDS.
HE IS AVERAGING 27 1/2 POINTS IN
THE TWO GAMES PLAYED AGAINST THE
CELTICS.
AND HE HIT THIS OVER IN THREE OF
THE LAST FIVE.
WITH AN UNHEALTHY STARTING
LINEUP FOR THIS KNICKS TEAM
TONIGHT, I REALLY LIKE JULIUS
RANDLE TO PRIORITIZE SCORING
TONIGHT AND HIT OVER 21 1/2
POINTS.
>> I LUKE TIKE THAT, LIV.
LET ME HOP INTO THE COMMENTS.
LET ME SEE WHAT THE PEOPLE ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
I HAVE -- WE ARE IN THE
COMMENTS.
WE ARE BETTING.
SM
MIKE IS IN THE COMMENTS.
YOU'RE BAWALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
MICHAEL RENER IS TAKING JULIUS
RANDLE.
SHOUTOUT TO BOTH OF YOU GUYS.
YOU TWO ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
I'LL HOP IN HERE, LIV.
THIS ONE IS TRICKY.
I'M GOING TO ROCK WITH JAYSON
TATUM.
I WANT YOU TO HEAR ME OUT.
HE SCORED 19 IN HIS LAST GAME
AGAINST -- IN A LOSS.
IT WAS A LOSS AGAINST SAN
ANTONIO.
HE STRUGGLED.
HE SHOT 6 FOR 20.
JAYSON TATUM IS COMING OFF OF A
ACCIDENT.
HE WAS IN HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROTOCOLS.
AND I THINK THAT HE'S GOING TO
BOUNCE BACK TO DATE.
HE'S GOING TO BE MORE AGGRESSIVE
BECAUSE HE KNOWS IN ORDER FOR
THAT CELTICS TEAM TO HAVE A
CHANCE AT WINNING TODAY, HE
NEEDS TO SCORE.
SO I LIKE HIM TO SCORE TONIGHT.
DO I THINK THE CELTICS ARE GOING
TO WIN?
NOT SO FAST.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT.
I JUST LIKE MY GUY J.T. TO PUT
UP SOME BUCKETS TONIGHT.
I WANT YOU TO REMEMBER, AFTER
THE GAME WE'RE GOING TO HIT UP
ONE PERSON AND HOOK YOU GUYS UP
WITH A JERSEY OF YOUR CHOICE.
LIV, IT'S MY FAVORITE PART OF
THE SHOW.
LET'S TALK MAJOR MARKETS MONEY
LINES AND AGAINST THE SPREADS.
AND POINT TOTALS FOR TONIGHT'S
GAME.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE ODDS,
LIVE.
ARE YOU SEEING -- I MEAN, WHAT
ARE YOU SEEING HERE IN -- WHAT
DO YOU LIKE?
>> TONIGHT, THERE IS NO AYTON
AND KNOW CROWDER.
THIS SUNS TEAM IS NOT AT FULL
HEALTH.
NEITHER IS THIS CLIPPERS TEAM.
THEY HAVE GONE UNDER.
51.4% OF THE SUNS MATCH YUUPS H
GONE UNDER.
I'M TAKING UNDER 220 1/2 IN THIS
MATCHUP.
>> LIV IS ROCKING WITH THE
UNDER.
OKAY, LIV.
I LIKE THAT.
ROCKING WITH THE TREND.
ROCKING WITH THE UNDER.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I GOT TO GO TO THE COMMENTS
BECAUSE I GOT TO SEE WHAT THEY
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
I GOT ELI.
ELI SAYS HE -- YES.
I'M GOING TO DO THE UNDER.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
BUT OFFICIALLY TATUM AND BROWN
WILL COMBINE FOR 63 POINTS, 28
POINTS FOR TATUM, 35 FOR BROWN.
BOSTON IS RUNNING AGAINST THE
SPREAD IN THE LAST FIVE.
I MEAN, THE KNICKS ARE HOME.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE HOME TEAM
HERE.
BOSTON, THEY'VE BEEN STRUGGLING
TO SCORE.
BOTH TEAMS PLAY DEFENSE.
BOSTON STRUGGLES.
THEY STRUGGLE CLOSE TO THE
BASKET.
THEY STRUGGLE TO DEFEND CLOSE TO
THE BASKET.
RANDAL IS DOWN.
THERE I THINK VEAL A GOOD GAME.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE KNICKS TO
WIN THIS ONE.
LET'S MOVE ON, LIV.
WE TALK MAJOR MARKETS.
NOW LET'S TALK PLAYER PROPS.
IT'S TIME FOR LOCK OR NOT.
I'M GOING TO PUT UP A PROP.
I NEED ALL OF YOU IN THE
COMMENTS TO TELL ME WHETHER IT
IS A LOCK IT'S NOT.
I WAS JUST TALKING ABOUT JULIUS
RANDLE.
SUPPOSED TO DOUBLE-DOUBLE
AGAINST THE CELTICS.
CURRENTLY AT MINUS 125.
TALK TO US, LIV.
PLEASE, TALK TO US LIKE YOU LIKE
THIS ONE.
>> I'M ONLY TALKING NICE RIGHT
NOW, OKAY?
I THINK IT'S A LOCK.
I DO LIKE THIS PLAY.
RANDAL HIT A DOUBLE-DOUBLE IN
FOUR OF THE LAST SIX WITH AN
UNHEALTHY KNICKS STARTING LINEUP
LIKE I MENTIONED EARLIER, I
THINK RANDAL HAS TO DO A LITTLE
BIT OF EVERYTHING.
I THINK HE WILL PRIORITIZE
SHOOTING AND REBOUNDING.
HE IS BOTTOM TEN IN REBOUNDS
ALLOWED.
NOT ONLY THAT, THEY ALSO ALLOW
THE THIRD MOST BOARDS TO
OPPOSING POWER FORWARDS.
AS YOU MENTIONED EARLIER, THE
SIXTH MOST POINTS TO OPPOSING
POWER FORWARDS.
SO THIS IS A BIG NIGHT FOR
JULIUS RANDLE.
SO JEWEL ULIUS RANDLE FOR A DOUS
A LOCK.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU, LIV.
I AGREE ABSOLUTELY.
I'M ROCKING WITH THAT.
I'M ROCKING WITH JULIUS RANDLE.
LIKE I SAID, THE SET ILT UKZ
STRUGG IKZ
STRUGGLE TO DEFEND THE PAINT.
WE KNOW WHAT HE DOES ON THE
BOARDS.
HE GRABS THEM CONSISTENTLY.
I'M ROCKING WITH JULIUS RANDLE
TO HIT THIS DOUBLE-DOUBLE.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS THOUGH.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
GRABBING THE HANDY DANDY.
I WANT TO SEE WHAT THE PEOPLE
ARE SAYING.
>> ELI.
HE SAYS, YEP, HE IS DOING THE
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALK AGO WAY WITH A
HOODIE.
SHOUTOUT TO BOTH OF YOU GUS.
YOU'RE WALK AGO WAY WITH A
HOODIE.
NEXT UP, IS SURGE TO REPORT
EIGHT PLUS REBOUNDS AT SITTING
PLUS 196?
>> THE VALUE, YOU LOOK THAT
VALUE AND THINK IT DOESN'T GET
MUCH BETTER THAN.
THAT THAT IS GREAT, GREAT VALUE.
ANY PLUS MONEY IS GREAT VALUE.
ESPECIALLY HERE.
WE HAVE STARTERS OUT FOR BOTH
THE CLIPPERS AND THE SUNS.
BOTH CENTERS ARE OUT FOR BOTH
THE CLIP AERNZ THE SUNS HERE.
SO THIS WOULDN'T BE A PLAY I PUT
MY RENT ON OR MY STUDENT LOAN
MONEY ON.
BUT A LITTLE SPRINKLE WHEN IT'S
AT PLUS 196 IS REALLY HARD TO
RESIST THIS ONE.
WITH THE STARTERS BEING OUT,
ESPECIALLY THOSE BEING CENTERS,
THERE'S A LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES
FOR BOARDS TONIGHT.
I THINK IT'S A NICE PLAY.
>> YOU MUST HAVE MONEY TO SPEND.
YOU MANY YOU HAVE MONEY TO
SPRINKLE ON WHATEVER.
MY GUY HASN'T DONE THIS SINCE
DECEMBER 20th.
VERSUS THE SPURS.
THAT'S BEFORE CHRISTMAS.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW, I'M COOL.
I'M COOL.
I AIN'T GOT MONEY TO SPEND LIKE
THAT.
I'M NOT ROCKING HIM TO GET 8
PLUS REBOUNDS.
YEAH, I'M COOL OFF THAT, LIV.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ONE.
FINALLY, WE HAVE CHRIS PAUL.
TO POST 15 OR MORE POINTS
AGAINST THE FORMER TEAM TONIGHT.
SITTING AT MUINUS 114.
YOU LIKE THIS ONE?
>> YEAH.
I'M GOING TO INITIALLY SAY IT'S
A LOCK.
WE SEE HIM PRIORITIZE SCORING.
I WORRY THAT HE MAY PRIORITIZE
SCORING OVER BEING THAT
FACILITATOR.
I WORRY HE'S GOING TO BE
FOCUSING ON SCORING.
FOR THE SAKE OF THIS BET, I
THINK IT'S A LOCK.
THE CLIPPERS ARE ALSO GIVING UP
AN AVERAGE OF ALMOST 24 POINTS
TO OPPOSING POINT GUARDS.
.
SO THIS IS A GOOD SPOT FOR PAUL
TONIGHT.
THERE IS NO AYTON OR CROWDER.
BOOKER, BRIDGES AND PAUL ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO SPLIT THAT
OFFENSIVE LOAD AMONG THE THREE
OF THEM TO GET THE JOB DONE
TONIGHT.
I WORRY ABOUT ASSISTS FOR HIM.
I THINK HE WILL PRIORITIZE
SCORING MORE.
I THINK IT'S A LOCK.
>> LIV, YOU HAVE SOME REALLY
GOOD POINTS THERE.
YOU'RE HITTING IT RIGHT ON THE
NAIL.
BEFORE I GIVE MY TAKE, I'M GOING
TO GET INTO THE COMMENTS.
I WANT TO SEE IF THEY'RE RIDING
WITH YOU.
AND THAT MIGHT DETERMINE WHAT
I'M GOING SAY.
BUT WE'RE GETTING SPAMED IN THE
COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
HE SAID THAT IS A LOCK.
HE'S GOING OFF WITH THE FIRE
EMOJI.
SHOUTOUT YOU TO.
USUALLY I DON'T GIVE THEM TO
SPAMERS.
WHY NOT?
IT'S THE NEW YEAR.
SO I'LL GIVE IT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALK AGO WAY WITH A -- D.
GEEK IS IN THE COMMENTS.
ITS A IN YOU YEAR.
THEREFORE, YOU'RE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
LIV, HE SAID THIS IS A LOCK.
I'M GOING TO ACKNOWLEDGE HIM I'M
GOING TO JUMP IN HERE.
THIS ONE IS SITTING AT MINUS 11
LIV.
CHRIS PAUL HASN'T SCORED 15 PLUS
POINTS SINCE CHRISTMAS.
SO I WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THIS
WOULD BE PLUS MONEY.
I WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THIS WOULD
HAVE BEEN PLUS MONEY.
IF HE HADN'T DONE IT IN WEEKS, I
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THIS WOULD
HAVE BEEN PLUS MONEY.
IT IS SITTING AT MINUS 114.
I THINK IT'S SITTING AT MINUS
114 FOR A REASON.
THE ODDS MAKERS, THEY KNOW CHRIS
PAUL IS FACING HIS FORMER TEAM
TONIGHT.
AND CHRIS PAUL IS GOING TO SHOW
UP.
SO, THEREFORE, I'M GOING TO ROCK
WITH CHRIS PAUL TO GO OVER.
I'M LOCKING THIS ONE IN.
I'M LOCKING THIS ONE IN, LIV.
I'M ROCKING WITH YOU.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE AUDIENCE.
IT IS TIME TO BUILD THE B/R
BETTING PARLAY.
YOU CAN JOIN WITH US ON FAN
DUEL.
TONIGHT, WE'RE DOING SOMETHING
SPECIAL.
IN HONOR OF BETTING BEING
LEGALIZED IN NEW YORK, WE'RE
DOING TWO SAME GAME PARLAYS.
ONE FOR EACH TNT GAME TONIGHT.
WHILE I GIVE UP -- I GIVE OUT
THE PARLAYS, I NEED EVERYBODY IN
THE COMMENTS TO TELL ME WHAT
THEY THINK.
WHICH LEGS ARE LOCKS.
WHICH LEGS ARE NOT?
AND LET'S START OFF WITH OUR NEW
YORK SPECIAL, LIV.
LET'S START OFF WITH THE NEW
YORK SPECIAL.
AND WE TALKED ABOUT THIS GUY.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT THROUGHOUT
THE SHOW.
YOU MENTIONED THEM.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THEM.
WE ACTUALLY DID THE PROP SEGMENT
ON HIM.
JULIUS RANDLE TO SCORE.
20 PLUS POINTS.
I LIKE IT.
I'M ROCKING WITH IT.
I MENTIONED -- I MENTIONED THE
CELTICS DEFENSE AROUND THE
PAINT.
THEY'VE BEEN STRUGGLING.
GIVE ME MY GUY TO GO 20 PLUS
TONIGHT.
ALEX BURKE.
ALEX BURKE TO RECORD TWO PLUS
ASSISTS TONIGHT, LIV.
THE FORMER WARRIOR, I CAN SEE
HIM GETTING IT DONE.
FINDING TWO OF HIS TEAMMATES.
THAT'S ALL WE NEED.
I ALSO MENTIONED THIS ONE
PREVIOUSLY.
KNICKS MONEY LINE.
I LIKE THIS ONE.
THEY'RE AT HOME.
PLUS MONEY.
GIVE ME THE KNICKS AT HOME.
AND R.J. BARRETT, THIS ONE KIND
OF SCARES ME, LIV.
RJ BARRETT, TWO PLUS THREE
POINTERS MADE.
LIV, TALK TO ME.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE NEW
YORK PARLAY?
>> I LIKE IT.
I THINK JULIUS RANDLE TO SCORE
20 PLUS IS A GREAT LEG.
LIKE I SAID EARLIER, HE IS
FACING A TEAM THAT STRUGGLES TO
GUARD THAT POWER FORWARD
POSITION.
BURKS WITH TWO PLUS ASSISTS, I
THINK THIS IS A GREAT PLAY.
HE HIT THIS FOUR OF THE LAST
FIVE.
I LAST I CHECKED, WE DIDN'T GET
KEMBA WALKER IN THIS ONE.
IF WE DON'T GET HIM, I LIKE THE
PLAY EVEN MORE.
KNICKS MONEY LINE, LISTEN,
CELTICS ARE HEALTHY RIGHT NOW.
THE KNICKS HAVE GOT TO PLAY SOME
GOOD DEFENSE IN ORDER TO WIN IN
THIS GAME.
I THINK IT'S POSSIBLE.
I HATE BETTING THE KNICKS WHEN
PLAYING AT HOME.
AND R.J. BARRETT, DEFINITELY
THIS LEG MAKES ME BE MOST
NERVOUS.
BUT IT'S POSSIBLE.
AND I THINK IF KNICKS MONEY LINE
IS GOING TO CASH, THEY NEED R.J.
BARRETT AT THE THREE POINT LINE
DRAINING THREES.
AT LEAST TWO.
SO IF THE KNICKS WANT TO WIN
THIS ONE, R.J. BARRETT HAS TO
HIT THREE BALLS.
THIS IS A GOOD LOOKING PARLAY TO
ME.
>> THAT'S FACTS.
THAT'S FACTS.
NOW LET'S TALK CLIPPERS TAKING
ON -- ACTUALLY, ACTUALLY, BEFORE
WE TALK CLIPPERS AND SUNS, I
WANT TO SHOW YOU GUYS THE
TICKET.
THEY ALREADY PULLED IT UP.
I WANT YOU WALKING AWAY WITH
$423 IF YOU PUT $100 ON THAT
LAST NEW YORK PARLAY.
NOW, LET'S TALK CLIPPERS VERSUS
SUNS.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT, LIV.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
DEVIN BOOKER TO SCORE 25 PLUS
POINTS.
HE'S THE D. BOOK.
I LIKE THIS ONE.
MOVING ON, CHRIS PAUL TO RECORD
10 PLUS ASSISTS.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO SCORE.
AND I ALSO THINK HE'S GOING TO
DISH TONIGHT.
I THINK CHRIS PAUL IS GOING TO
HAVE A BIG GAME TONIGHT.
HE IS FACING HIS FORMER TEAM.
I LIKE THIS ONE.
REGGIE JACKSON, WE KNOW WHAT HE
DOES.
HE IS A BUCKET.
REGGIE JACKSON.
WHENEVER IT'S A CLUTCH MOMENT
AND NEED A BUCKET, I WOULD
DEPEND ON REGGIE JACKSON.
I NEED 15.
I THINK REGGIE CAN DELIVER.
AND CAM JOHNSON, YEAH, I'M
FEELING GOOD ABOUT THIS ONE,
LIV.
BEFORE I GET INTO THE COMMENTS,
NO.
ACTUALLY, BEFORE I GET INTO THE
DETAILS, TALK TO ME.
DO YOU LIKE THIS ONE?
TELL ME YOUR OPINION ON IT?
>> I LIKE THE SAME GAME PARLAY.
DEVIN BOOK WE ARE A STARTING
LINEUP NOT COMPLETELY HEALTHY.
HE IS THE ONE I TRUST THE MOST
TO SCORE TONIGHT.
HE WAS OUT WITH HIS HAMSTRING
INJURY.
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO GUARD
BOOKER.
I THINK HE IS THE SECRET WEAPON.
CHRIS PAUL WITH TEN PLUS ASSISTS
IS THE ONE THAT MAKES ME THE
MOST NERVOUS.
LIKE YOU SAID, IF YOU THINK THIS
IS A BIG NIGHT FOR CHRIS PAUL,
THERE MAY BE VALUE IN SPRINKLING
ON MAYBE A DOUBLE-DOUBLE FOR HIM
TONIGHT IF YOU THINK HE'LL DO
BOTH.
THAT IS SOMETHING TO CONSIDER.
MAKES ME TINY NERVOUS.
HE HAD 19 THE LAST TIME HE
PLAYED THE SUNS THIS SEASON.
THE SUNS ALLOW THE THIRD MOST
POINTS TO OPPOSING POINT GUARDS.
I LOVE THE SPOT FOR REGGIE
TONIGHT.
FINALLY, JOHNSON WITH TREE PLUS
THREE, I LOVE THIS LEG.
HE HIT THIS IN THE LAST MEETING
WITH THE CLIPPERS W NO CROWDER
TO NIGHT, I LIKE HIM TO GET
VALUABLE PLAYING TIME.
I LOVE THIS LEG.
I THINK OVERALL IT'S THE SLAM
DUNK PARLAY.
>> WHICH IS YOUR FAVORITE
PARLAY?
>> I THINK MY FAVORITE PARLAY
HAS GOT TO BE THIS
CLIPPERS-SUNS.
I THINK ALL THE LEGS MAKE SENSE.
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO GET A
NICE GAME THAT WE MATCH UP
BETWEEN THE TWO TEAMS AND THE
LAST TIME WE SAW THE TEAMS PLAY,
IT DIDN'T GO AS PEOPLE PROBABLY
EXPECTED.
THE CLIPPERS CAME OUT ON TOP.
I DON'T THINK YOU'LL SEE THAT
AGAIN TONIGHT.
SO I'M LIKING THE SAME GAME
PARLAY AND IT SHOULD HIT.
>> I'M ROCKING WITH BOTH OF
THEM.
GO SPRINKLE BOTH OF THEM.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I WANT TO SEE WHAT THE PEOPLE
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
OFFICIALLY CUT SAYS SUNS MINUS
2 1/2.
BOOKER IS GOING FOR 30.
THE PLUS 25 IS A NO-BRAINER.
TAKE THE UNDER 15 ON PAUL
ASSISTS.
APPRECIATE THAT.
SHOUTOUT YOU TO.
YOU'RE WALK AGO WAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I'M ALSO GIVING AWAY A JERSEY.
I'M LOOK FORG A GOOD TAKE.
I HAVE JULIO HERNANDEZ.
BOTH OF THE PARLAYS ARE A PLUS.
RANDAL GOING OFF AGAINST THE
CELTICS.
DEFENSE TONIGHT.
BURKS CAN EASILY GET TWO
ASSISTS.
BARRETT WILL HIT TWO THREES I
LOVE THE SHOTS OF YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
LIV, ITS TIME TO GIVE AWAY A
JERSEY.
I WANT COMMENTS.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
NOT TODAY.
IF YOU TUNE IN TO WINNERS ONLY
WEDNESDAYS, THAT'S ONE OF THE
SLOGANS.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
APPRECIATE THAT.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY OF YOUR CHOICE.
WE TALK MVPs A FEW TIMES ON THE
SHOW.
AND NOW YOU KNOW -- YOU GUYS
KNOW, I STILL LOVE STEPH CURRY
TO WIN THE MVP.
K.D. IS JUST NOW BEHIND STEPH.
AND JONAS IS SURGING AS WELL.
I NEED YOU TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHO IS YOUR
LOCK TO WIN MVP?
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE ODDS.
LIV, WHAT IS THE BEST VALUE ON
THE BOARD?
DO YOU THINK DEROSEN IS GOOD
LONG SHOT BET AT PLUS 4,000?
>> I HAVE ANOTHER LONG SHOT BET
IN MIND.
GIVE ME JA MURANT AT PLUS 5500.
I GOT TO BE HONEST.
I AM A JA MURANT FAN GIRL.
I'M NOT AFRAID TO ADMIT IT.
HE IS PLAYING NEXT LEVEL
BASKETBALL.
I ALSO THINK THIS GRIZZLIES TEAM
IS EXTREMELY UNDERESTIMATED.
I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO GO MUCH
FURTHER THAN PEOPLE ANTICIPATE.
WE KNOW THAT WITH THE MVP
CONVERSATION, A LOT OF PEOPLE
SAY THAT IT'S A POPULARITY
CONTEST.
YOU KIND OF GOT TO BE ON WANING
TEAM.
I THINK THE GRIZZLIES ARE GOING
TO WIN MORE THAN PEOPLE
ANTICIPATE.
I THINK JA MURANT IS PLAYING OUT
OF HIS MIND.
I ACTUALLY GRABBED HIM BEFORE
THE SEASON STARTED AT PLUS 3200.
OR MAYBE A COUPLE WEEKS INTO THE
SEASON.
THEN HE GOT INJURED.
NOW IT'S AT PLUS 5500.
I'M SPRINKLING ON IT ALL OVER
AGAIN.
I LOVE IT.
IT'S WORTH A SPRINKLE.
>> LIV, I LIKE THAT.
I LIKE THAT.
IF I HAD A LONG SHOT, IF I HE
WASN'T BETTING A LONG SHOT, I'D
BE RIDING WITH YOU.
JA IS BLOWING THIS YEAR.
THIS MVP TAKES A RUN.
HE CAN TAKE THAT TEAM ON A RUN.
AND, YOU KNOW, IF HE HAS A PUSH
FOR TWO TO THREE MONTHS AND
TAKES HIS TEAM FROM, YOU KNOW, A
LOWER SEED TO A HIGHER SEED, I
CAN SEE THAT ACTUALLY HAPPENING.
IF THAT IS SOMEONE I'M GOING TO
ROCK WITH.
I WILL SAY, MY GUY K.D.
K.D. SLIS THE BEST PLAYER IN TH
NBA.
HE JUST GOT HIS SIDEKICK BACK IN
KYRIE IRVING.
I LIKE WHAT HE'S DOING OUT THERE
IN GOLDEN STATE.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I WANT TO SEE WHO THE PEOPLE ARE
TAKING.
I GOT DEMARIO.
HE SAYS KD ALL THE WAY.
SHUTOUT TO YOU.
D. GEEK SAYS I'M BIASSED.
I'M BIASSED.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
HOW AM I BIASSED IF STEPH CURRY
IS THE FAVORITE TO WIN THE MVP?
HOW IS THAT BEING BIASSED?
HE'S THE FAVORITE FOR A REASON.
SO I'M ROCKING WITH STEPH.
>> HE IS A WARRIORS FAN.
>> ALL RIGHT.
I AM A WARRIORS FAN BOY.
I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW IT
IS BIASSED IF STEPH CURRY IS THE
FAVORITE TO WIN ALREADY.
YOU NO HE WHAT I'M SAYING?
YEAH.
ANYWAY.
LET ME GIVE AWAY MORE HOODIES.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
WE GOT ONE MORE HOODIE IN ME.
I ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH LIV.
JA IS GOING TO LEAD THIS TEAM IN
CARRIES AND HE ALSO HAS A CHIP
ON HIS SHOULDER TO SHOW THE
FANS, TO SHOW THE FANS WHAT IT
IS.
MY BOY MIKE IS IN THE COMMENTS.
HE SAYS DEROSEN IS GETTING
PLAYED.
SHOUTOUT TO EVERYBODY THAT I
MENTIONED.
YOU ALL ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
ALL RIGHT, LIV, IT'S TIME TO
TAKE THIS THING HOME.
THANK YOU GUYS FOR TAPPING INTO
THE GROUP CHAT PRESENTED BY FAN
DUEL.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED TODAY.
THE KNICKS-CELTICS THREE BY TWO
IS A LOCK.
ALSO, THE OTHER GAME IS A LOCK.
SPRINKLE THEM BOTH.
GET ON FAN DUEL AND TELL OUR B/R
BETTING PARLAYS.
IF YOU WIN IN NEW YORK, GET ON
FAN DUEL AND SIGN UP.
BE READY TO BET ON SATURDAY
MORNING.
THAT'S WHEN BETTING BECOMES
LEGAL AT 9:00 A.M. EASTERN TIME.
WE'LL BE BACK NEXT THURSDAY.
GIVING OUT MORE HOODIES, MORE
LOCKS AND MORE JERSEYS AND
GIVING AWAY SOMETHING SPECIAL.
VERY SPECIAL.
MY WARRIORS ARE TAKING ON THE
MILWAUKEE BUCKS.
IF YOU WANT A HOODIE TODAY, IF
YOU WON A HOODIE TODAY, WE WILL
BE WITH YOU ALONGSIDE LIV, I'M
GREG.
WE'RE LEAVING THE GROUP CHAT.
PEACE.